hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to I Wally okay so I've
been employing strange methods to try to
get away from this guy and I believe
that I may have been right in my
assumption that all I need to do is get
away from him instead of going on these
complicated routes trying to go around
and around and around when in reality
what I may only need to do is just get
the Frick frack out of here maybe maybe
I'm not on oh no oh maybe maybe maybe
maybe maybe baby oh yeah maybe baby
maybe not maybe not maybe not okay I'm
wrong I'm wrong I'm wrong wrong again
room I'm right I'm right I'm right I'm
right I'm right I'm right he's gone he's
gone he's gone he's gone he's gone yay I
did it I did it I did it I did it
okay so I got a rope ladder and
something else wait no I was supposed to
do something upstairs that's right I
only got distracted because I was
running away from that stupid [ __ ] he
looked like a dude oamaru or whatever
dummy Adam agachi a dumb Oguchi Adam
Robbie a dumb oh you know a dumb oh yeah
I got a blue piece what does that mean
why do I have a blue piece wasn't there
already a blue piece why do I need to
believe these ah maybe I need to fill it
all with blue pieces maybe that's what I
need to do okay cool what do I do
well what do I do with that what do I do
about that and with that and why why
maybe I can put the blue piece in
instead of another one if I take that
out no the door locks behind me so
there's got to be something else that I
do do so that means I've got two blue
pieces but no all right I'm not ready
for this just yet I'm not ready for that
just yet I gotta find a way to get that
oh I know I know I need the role letter
because I need to be able to get out of
here I need to be able to go over there
and put
there and good gonna get we get together
by the robe ladder over there because
I'm gonna oh yeah because I'm gonna be
able to get out of here once I get that
blue peas and this blade lock down I'm a
genius I'm a genius I'm a genius I'm a
genius actually I'm probably average
intelligence - everyone else is trying
to beat this game yeah of all the people
that have done playthroughs games I'm
the average yeast alright so what else
did I get
I have two blue pieces now wasn't there
something else that had to be something
else that I missed something
oh yeah I want to check the safe that's
right the safe over here because he
chased me away from there first
yeah that's right was there something
over here Easter Egg maybe secret Luigi
I can't stand up there hang on let me
grab this chair over here cuz I'm just a
shorty shorty trim yep yep no oh crap
alrighty then
let me do this was there something
written here something here here nah oh
not another puzzle I hate puzzles had
puzzles hot pockets
yeah oh no that wasn't it okay there's
two bookshelves there's five paintings
on the wall there's one two three four
five six objects on the table and four
screws in the hole - five six four two
two five six
whoa now well there's 1841 divided by
the 78 car carry the three until you get
to the and then you go around and what
do you know it's gonna be is gonna
get it do what he's gonna be oh I forgot
to carry the three till we keep 100 that
makes so much sense okay closing that
out sorry I had to consult the wiki I
was totally at a loss there I would
never have guessed what it told me to do
hang on yeah I would have never guessed
never ever ever ever ever ever ever
would have guessed what I was supposed
to do if it hadn't told me this so this
was useful I apologize
please don't hate me you knew you could
never hate me just like I hate it's what
I'm supposed to do is I'm supposed to
hang in with ya yeah oh I would have
never let this makes so much sense
oh you're supposed to count the size
three I guess circle zero right three
zero four five three zero four or five
oh I would have never in a million years
gotten that three zero four five and
that'll give me the last blue piece and
then I can go over here and then go
along my merry way and finally get some
progress three zero four five three zero
four Oh No yeah yeah all right
blue piece basement key almost blue
piece not quite blue piece but almost
good enough I'll take it whatever it is
I'll take it
yes yes yeah all right yeah all right
all right all right all right
I apologize everybody for having the
little walkthrough but you don't want to
be to be wallowing in misery as I try
this all those do you oh wait no not
that one
maybe there was there was another door
over here right now there's another door
over here this is just gonna open it out
it's gonna help everybody I love you I
love each and every one of you I love
you what the hell why the hell
holy crap well I'm gonna shoot myself in
the face because I'm never gonna have
nightmares light as ever before in my
life oh no he though I got through I
don't know I don't know oh no no no no
he's not yeah that was a close call liar
no no no no no I don't trust you I don't
trust you as far as I could throw you
you're all of those monsters why would I
trust him why in a million years I saw
him get garbled I guess I didn't see him
get garbled but I'm gonna go out on a
limb and assume that oh look I didn't
him that was good that was good game
that was well done though you son of a
[ __ ] that was very well done that was
good that was very good oh my god you
son of a [ __ ] you son of a [ __ ] oh you
know it okay wait you mother ah ah did I
we're gonna go
you're gonna follow me we're gonna go
over here we're gonna go around we're
gonna go down there you're gonna go here
you're gonna be a son of a [ __ ] and I'm
gonna go up here oh no excuse me pardon
me
need to go this way you need to go kill
yourself and I'm gonna go back
downstairs now Thank You Pere Lachaise
go away I knew I knew that was gonna be
a problem I knew it I knew that I think
everybody knew that I'm not I'm not
acting like I'm some amazing detective
like I knew he was gonna betray me but
barely everybody wait a minute they're
blue pieces they're blue monsters purple
purple purple blue blue purple I don't
know I think when I played Kuro Oni i
discovered that Kuro was black so I
think hi hi friend oh I'm gettin outta
here you're gonna go now go away go away
you gone I'm gone I'm out of there I'm
out of there yeah cry you can't see like
teardrops in the rain
I'm ran and ran until I got back to town
the monster was no longer following me
and the mansion got blown to hell what
was that blue thing I don't know but
tokoro and the others are still missing
to this day
hello what the hell what what was that
what was that what what Oh what why did
some other stupid a-hole go into that
place good job you're dead
congratulation Oh ha ha okay that was
really really fun that was actually a
ton of fun I enjoyed that immensely that
was phenomenal some of those scares were
really well done and the overall just
creepy atmosphere the entire time was
spectacular now if I could make any sort
of like criticism about it if you set
the main character's name - timer what
what'll happen what'll happen I'm not
going to do that I can't even figure out
how to backspace but I mean if I could
criticize anything about it is that
there probably wasn't enough music to
the game it kind of got repetitive with
the chase music and there was kind of
repetitive with the jail I mean they
kind of mixed it up with the tastings
but at the end of the day was pretty
repetitive and some of the puzzles were
a little out there but either way that
was fantastic hope you guys enjoyed it I
think by now I am back in town and
recording videos again this whole series
was done all in one go so I could see it
all live and in person so thank you all
so much for watching I will try to get
to working em and there were some bugs
with it I don't know even I only took
some work to try to get it to work so
thank you all so much for watching
though excuse me click the annotations
for more videos that I've done and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye-bye
Oh
whoa
hmm
Oh actually I'm gonna cut it here thank
you